il existe beaucoup d'histoires à dormir
debout ou plutôt à ne pas dormir du tout
notamment si votre maison est hantée nan
nan vraiment et avec des fantômes qui
font et des effets qui squattent votre
habitation sans même payer de loyer ce
qui est le cas de véronique geoffroy et
son mari qui ont investi ce château de
fougères et en 2009 mais qui visiblement
ont eu affaire à des colocataires assez
flippant j'ai vu une silhouette
masculine ça c'est sûr et certain on
avait eu des phénomènes tactile et les
phénomènes visuels beaucoup m'ont à des
phénomènes d'odeurs on ne sait pas
vraiment si l'intervention de médium sur
les lieux a été suffisante pour se
débarrasser des êtres indésirables ont
gâté choisi 6 1 c'est clair en tout cas
les preuves d'existence d'esprit dans
leurs résidences sont si nombreuses
qu'on imagine volontiers qu'ils ne
doivent pas vivre leur best life avec
autant de fantômes ne peut pas dire que
ce soit très simple tous les jours quand
même ce soit la propriétaire du lieu
véronique geoffroy est avec nous
pourrons parler
comme ça il ya les sceptiques mais on va
découvrir ça ensemble vous votre votre
château il est vraiment et quoi oui y'a
aucun doute non alors on a vu une
personne jeter de du coca cola
c'est qu'est ce que c'était que ça ben
je sais pas c'est des potions et c'est
pour nous protéger mais en fait ça n'a
rien changé alors moi je veux tout je
veux tout savoir bon on achète le sa
tournée content on n'attire pas piéger
le notaire on va se faire plaisir on
arrive c'est soit ac à quel moment on y
tient c'est bizarre j'avais laissé la
porte semble ouverte c'est ça en fait
bah en fait c'est venu assez rapidement
on entendait des voix on a vu des
silhouettes passé mais on a mis du temps
à réaliser face le dira cela vous et que
c'était vraiment et pas parce que comme
ça peu pris la loro ça n'existe pas ça
on doute fort sans doute alors on a un
premier enregistrement
alors on a la voix d'un homme énervé
pendant une visite écoutez
[Musique]
alors mais ça on l'entend sur le moment
où c'est après en réécoutant les deux
allées de fait en transe comme on peut
entendre à la réécoute mais les gens
vraiment super ouvert ils peuvent
entendre en direct toi alors on a un
autre extrait c'est la voix d'un homme
qui répète ce que dit une femme
apparemment c'est un perroquet
[Applaudissements]
blessé mais c'est à dire on est sûr que
c'est pas c'est pas un copain qui au
fait
on a croisé bon on en est encore en a on
en a plein on en a plein j'ai vraiment
la trouille alors alors là c'est la
lassitude voix d'enfants qu'ils
demandent c'est qui dans la sa mère
alors plus la base des formes comme dans
les films offre
mais en fait c'est vrai que ça fait
cliché tout ça mais mais là aujourd'hui
je suis devenu très curieuse de tout ça
donc c'est presque un laboratoire
fougerais mais c'est passionnant fait
alors on va parler après mais vous avez
reçus des scientifiques vous avez des
expériences pour mesurer j'ai pas
laissez moi j'ai vu les gays j'ai vu et
ce sans tome mais on peut mesurer le
côté de la dose ectoplasmique par
exemple
j'ai conduit la doudoune ectoplasmique
présence énergétique alors ouais non
mais les scientifiques il se mouille pas
c'est ça le problème nous on a vu des
trucs incroyables et quand j'ai voulu
appeler des scientifiques il voulait pas
se mouiller parce qu'ils sont pas
d'explication les gars nous on a vu des
objets traverser les murs je vous jure
c'est vraiment incroyable non on a eu
des phénomènes de poltergeist de dengue
et des scientifiques ils se déplacent
pas il n'y a pas un champ de cbd près du
château
mais c'est pour ça donc c'est je pense
que tu rassurer alors on a un autre
enregistrement là c'est une voix qui
s'excuse d'avoir fait peur à quelqu'un
m'a dit avoir demandé j'ai peur qu'ils
s'excusent déjà écouté
non mais alors donc si je comprends bien
vous êtes dans votre château est en fait
plus parler à haute voix et en fait on
vous répond
il ya quoi à manger il ya des smaghi
bolognaise c'est à voter non mais c'est
ouf quand même mais c'est assez
incroyable non mais ça alors on va on va
continuer parce que visiblement ça vous
arrive tout le temps moi je pourrais
plus vivre dans le tourisme soit je
voulais qu'il est resté dans le château
en fait il ya un bandana non gelée mis
en vente en 2008 elle a logé
le ccsa mais en fait personne n'en
voulait après ben en même temps je me
comprends alors il ya un autre il ya en
outre justement la suivront c'est
vraiment peu il dit une voix qui dit je
vais ça oui oui ça c'est vrai ah oui ça
vers lé bas aulas
mais tu n'es pas les impôts c'est le
point des propriétaires de fougeret qui
a assassiné un huissier à coups de hache
et donc on parlait des impôts il a dit
je hais en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les voix c'est pas ils disent
pas n'importe quoi c'est hyper cohérent
avec ce que nous ont dit avec le
contexte quoi à la bascule mais parce
que vous avez fait des recherches à
plein j'ai fait plein de recherche
assistée ont ils prennent pas pour des
cinglés quand même alors non non non
juste mais on était tous le le moment
qui vous a fait le plus flipper ben moi
franchement est déjà là on est bien
là franchement on est bien mais vraiment
le truc vraiment incroyable quoi basse
et les premiers phénomènes de paul
tergat ce que j'ai vu où on a des
déplacements d'objets on a des trucs qui
tombent du plafond qui était au deuxième
étage qui nous arrive comme ça c'est
vous êtes donc dans votre salon ouais il
ya jean le guéridon du dessus qui passe
de qui passe sous la route et ça fait un
espèce de trou noir a vortex et vous
avez un livre qui passe et d'un seul
coup non mais je sais c'est fou hein moi
toi et moi pas par principe je vous
crois pas ce que j'ai vécu particulier
mais pas ça abbas alors ouais moi pour
moi c'était le level max a nommé donc on
voit où le plafond est là il ya comme un
nuage en fait ça fait 1 ça fait une
espèce de tache noire et il ya un objet
qui traverse la tâche disparaît est
l'objet qu'on le récupère il est chaud
c'est très fort alors gilles moi quelque
chose m'étonne madame il ya des lieux
hantés par des ancêtres notamment cinq
ans vous avez acheté le château les
propriétaires précédents ne vous ont pas
averti nom et vous n'avez pas examiner
s'il était hanté pas et moi quand je
change de logements j'examine cissé
j
mais la meilleure des choses
ici une cuisine salle de bains et
dites-moi les fantômes il n'y en a pas
sinon il vous à risques est arrivé alors
fait venir un médian concrètement je
prends des renseignements avec des gens
qui travaillent là dedans je peux
appeler marabout je parle
de quoi il faut tourner plusieurs alors
vous n'êtes pas rester pendant des nuits
entières tous ensemble avec magna vous
auriez évité le pire mais là
on a on a encore une fois encore alors
il part alors il parait pas tour dans
ces histoires de maison hantée qu' il ya
des fantômes en fête qui préfèrent
certaines saillies que d'autres il ya
des lieux qui n'ont jamais connu aucune
manifestation le fantôme et ça n'arrive
qu'à qu'à une famille amityville la
médecine c'est arrivé qu'à une seule
famille et jamais plus après et j'ai
jamais avant que forcément il faut tous
bords mais oui mais jamais plaint mais
c'est vrai ben c'est vrai madame je ne
veux pas du tout et désobligeants mais
pour moi c'est un truc de zozo c'est un
truc de taxes des descentes en
distribuant le riche pour se faire peur
ils vont venir chez vous dans votre
atelier
[Applaudissements]
les présidents à part tout à
fait remise et compte attirer attirer
tout de suite one ans
tu vas voir ce qui va t'arriver sur toi
alors en quoi tu veux on a encore un
autre enregistrement c'est un appel à
l'aide oui je me casse direct
c'est l'huissier qui s'est fait
assassiner à coups de hache alors par
louis et qui nous a demandé de l'aide
absolument donc c'est l'huissier oui et
qu'elle avait donc trier oui on vous
avait en fait mené l enquête oui il ya
un huissier qu'il n'y aurait jamais des
sous oui et c'était coutumes des
morceaux qui suivait tué à coups de
hache par approprient mais c'est là où
devait habiter mois
mais malia des bonbons madame je vous
dis franchement je vous crois parce que
on avait d'ailleurs fait un sujet pour
pour pour cyril ici moi que j'avais
habiter une maison occupée dans le
neuvième art aux arrondissements et
j'entendais des bruits de bottes nivard
est déjà tournée
et on a mené une enquête et la maison
avait appartenu à monsieur godillots qui
est l'inventeur de la botte donc son âme
était dans les couloirs c'est pourquoi
j'entends des bruits de bottes quand
c'est la maison de bodio passer l'amour
diction qui vous ai fait une blague le
curé pas du tout
passage en temps la merde aznavour qui
chantent
[Rires]
alors on à cronat on a encore un
enregistrement à
moi je veux que vous passer une sale
nuit
vous avez dit que les scientifiques
n'avaient pas donné de réponse
rationnelle c'est normal dont vous avez
fait appel à des médiums ce canal est
très bon qui permettent aux énergies au
fantôme de partir et d'aller dans une
autre sphère alors oui il ya des c'est
vrai que c'est un peu l'image ans
fairway les fantômes ils sont tous
malheureux faut les aider à partir il y
en a qui ont accepté de partir et il y
en a qui ont refusé parce que ils
étaient encore accrochés à une espèce de
vibrations matériel de ton bien sûr ils
sont bien le coton ou total ils sont
trop d'ailleurs ayant là ils sont
tellement bien que on communique souvent
avec elle alors des conseils ils sont de
bons conseils en plus en jeu laissez
avec les numéros du loto dont
on a un autre enregistrement il nous
dirait qui est cette personne
schelin alors
qu'angelina c'est la maman de felix et
phoenix c'est mon fantôme entre
guillemets préféré c'est à lui je
demande toujours conseil quand j'ai des
doutes dans la vie sur un gros truc il
m'a averti de choses d'ailleurs j'ai pas
voulu l'écouter qui me sont arrivées
après comme quoi comme quoi pas mais
plein de choses dans le national bat de
faire gaffe à intel par exemple je
faisais pas attention et je me suis pris
des manches de pioche terrible avec ses
excellents alors j'imagine aussi en lice
et métaphorique il ya pas un ange qui a
volé
des déceptions donc accord mais non
franchement c'est quelqu'un de très bons
conseils angelina c'est sa mère donc je
suppose que c'est son mari dans acquis
qu'ils appellent angelina on sait que
l'époque ils ont vécu alors félix il est
mort en 1899
non
204 les huit on disait d'appareils photo
gerald
soyez soyez un petit peu croyante je
vous le jure il ya plein il ya plein
d'histoires et tout ces gens là ne sont
pas fous moi j'ai vu le travail
traverser un guéridon chez moi qui se
dépasser
alors vous avez une autre anecdote quoi
c'est un c'est une plaie c'est un
journaliste un journal est assez drôle
saint avold bas voici à quoi bon c'est
bon c'est bon c'est pas pareil allez-y
de journée et là on fait ça couple de
journalistes qui étaient venus pour
faire un reportage et ils ont dormi tous
les deux dans la chambre d'alice qui a
lu ce alice alors c'est une jeune fille
qui est décédée en 1980 va bien
régulièrement et le lendemain on faisait
une séance de spiritisme avec une médium
et les journalistes étaient là et en
fait on a eu des détails un petit peu
voilà sur sur la nuitée et on a compris
que voilà il ya vu adultère j'étais
super g n'est n'empêche donc bon c'est
pas passé dans le reportage mais nous ça
m'a fait marrer enfin alors si je compte
si je résume en fait vous allez donc
faire un reportage avec avec un collègue
mais cela n'est ce pas ce qui se passe
et c'est le fantôme qui nous balance
c'est vrai c'est quoi l'anecdote du
chocolat chaud c'est notre série bien
évidemment nous n'arrêtons chocolat mais
non en fait on était en train de faire
un shooting photo de mode il fait super
froid et j'étais au rez de chaussée et
avec ma fille on regardait les espèces
de trophées de chasse et je lui disais
que c'était horrible et je voulais les
enlever cette émis par des propriétaires
en 1920 et je lui dis au même moment
mais moi j'ai des photos de 1920 où on
les voit boire du chocolat et au même
moment dans tout château et les plafonds
et tout s'est complètement c'est le
plafond jeu ça s'est mis à sentir le
chocolat chaud mais super fort c'est
bien que soit qu'ils aient un shooting
photo aux premiers sont descendus ils
croyaient qu'on en avait fait et l'odeur
a disparu comme elle est venue alors
physiquement on a essayé on a mis un
trépied on a fait bouillir du lait on a
mis du chocolat et ça sentait
et les phénomènes alpha ctif cd
phénomène au même titre que les
phénomènes audio les phénomènes visuels
c'est bien chez vous avez un truc c'est
normal tu veux comme tu es
franchement moi je suis je trouve ça
incroyable vous louer des chambres pour
le pour le week-end
est-ce que les impressions
fantasmagorique et actions quotidiennes
dans votre genre alors justement c'est
pas quotidien n'y a pas de fréquence
donc on est assez surpris et on peut pas
prévoir en fait
quelqu'un qu'elles
ont d'ailleurs été les mots cohabiter
mais en fait finalement maintenant ça
fait 12 ans pour biffer un ba oui mais
avant dites moi ce que vous étiez
sensible à tous là où je sais je me
posais des questions mais j'étais pas
comme aujourd'hui là vraiment je fais
vraiment des recherches a bien su
moi j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
historiques sur le château déjà pour
savoir qui y est écrit ce qui s'était
passé et maintenant je suis je fais des
meilleures et j'avais aussi des
phénomènes de des portes qui se
verrouille tout seul oui alors ça ça
fait partie des phénomènes de
poltergeist ou déplacement d'objets
bougeait pas ah oui ça c'est important
j'ai eu des lotos j'ai eu des phénomènes
en fait de verrous qui serait sacré en
fait je me suis retrouvé moi la porte
mais comme dans les films on entend la
porte qui claque en tant qu lac mercier
longtemps mais c'est à vous avez
d'autres choses qui vous sont arrivés
parce que la relève tarde déjà bien mais
mais vous avez d'autres d'autres
anecdotes on en a plein des vallées du
lot j ai pas d des silhouettes des
phénomènes tactile aussi on a on a une
médium un jour qu'ils avaient les mains
dans ses poches se balader au second
thème dis merde où sont mes clés je
rentre dans une pièce et joie un jeu de
clés tombé du plafond sur le tapis et
c'était ses clés comme ça c'est du
poltergeist à fond ça c'est un classique
et une salle a rien d'inquiétant cct du
portugais
tiago poltergeist de base ben c'est ce
que je dis aux gens quand les jets une
excellente compagnie qué parce qu'il ya
forcément des gens qui viennent et quand
ils ont des choses trop importante il
panique en fait j'aime à jules lorsque
par exemple j'avais un petit objet une
bobine de fil dmc bon bref eux car était
pas de voler tout seul en tout chaque
jour est un jour j'étais au rez de
chaussée elle était au second gersois
sur mois déjà et un jour elle disparaît
et gt gt un peu peiné je vois c'est
dommage et tout et j'ai une cliente
kayes dans la chambre de l'huissier et
qui use et des coopérants elle peut
suivre
c'est bien que la bobine est sorti du
mur elle l'a vu sortir du mur quoi et ça
c'est c'est hallucinant si vous avez des
enfants oui 3 eyes lips a bien aussi les
enfants vannes aujourd'hui vous ça
revient à grand village que moi monde
mon dernier ne dors très mal s'il vient
chez vous il dort plus jamais de sa vie
va
s'expliquer parce que qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire à des enfants connais des
phénomènes parce que on trouvera
quelques photos de dons à des photos
d'ariary d'apparition
des photos qui sont passées mais comme
on ne peut expliquer à son enfant ni bah
voilà bah ça c'est à ressasser un
guichet bon il est venu il demandait des
ronds et c'est de couper en petits bouts
c'est quand même c'est comme quand tu
démarres et tous les visites
tous les suicides
et bien vous savez que la seule fois que
j'ai eu un huissier qui a accepté de
dormir dans cette chambre d'habitude les
phénomènes de poltergeist les objets
valdingue dans les pièces mais ça
atteint jamais personne et la seule fois
où un mec s'est pris un crucifix sur le
front non je savais pas le métier qu'ils
faisaient là j'étais un peu gêné parce
que le but c'est pas que les mecs
arrivent neuf appartements et il m'a dit
c'est peut-être parce que je suis
huissière sur le coup j'ai été étonné et
c'est le seul quand il ya des gens qui
sont là pour avancer c'est toi qui sont
totalement
réfractaire ça que ya des gens qui
viennent qui viennent et ils ne voient
rien ils sont en rien arriver arriva
corps humain bien sûr il n'a pas
expliqué que c'était peut-être une
projection de se libérer dans votre
cerveau que tout ça était était dans
notre tête non non non parce que tout ce
qu'on a vécu on l'a vécu avec des
témoins mais avec des amis des visites à
la d'autant qu'ils ont mieux et on
n'était pas assez compliquée vive sa
seule on n'aura aucune crédibilité s'il
devait pas réussi à filmer par exemple
alors ça c'est marrant j'en parlais dans
les loges tout à l'heure c'est hyper
difficile de les filmer par exemple un
jour au rez de chaussée on entend un
espèce de bruit score des fois il ya des
bruits fracassants dans les étages et
c'était une boule d'un jeu de croquet
qui descendait tous les étages et ses
des escaliers en vis donc ça faisait
toutes les marches avec line klainguer
en fait la boule de croquer et suivez le
truc sinon elle serait ce qu'un autre
loi et au moment au rez de chaussée où
on a vu ça sur lequel on a voulu filmer
évidemment est en fait ben non mais le
le téléphone coupe tout fins et laissant
peut pas c'est bizarre il ya trop de
charges avec topic mais tous ces morts
là sont des morts violentes la plupart
c'est alors félix par exemple il a mis
fin à ses jours en lui c'est un
personnage de maupassant il a vraiment
une vie de grands romantiques était
assez jeune alice elle est décédé de
maladie l'huissier s'est fait une offre
couplant morceaux
il ya une bonne charge de bazens évacuer
dans les 48 heures franchement on est
vraiment étonné un merci pour ceux des
ménages parce que vraiment c'est jamais
ses classes en déclassant